welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in birds-of-prey as an official
trailer for the burst comic book film of
2020 margot robbie reprised in her DC
antihero Harley Quinn from Suicide Squad
and a team of film b-tree and the women
of DC's birds of prey Huntress Black
Canary Renee Montoya as they all face
against you and McGregor as crime Lord
Roman sea onus black mask director Kathy
Ann is making this movie look like the
inside of a pinata and I ain't
complainin but within this confetti
storm are actually some interesting
visual clues that explain a lot about
what this movie might be I'm gonna
explain it all shot by shot in boiler
warning the case any my predictions and
being too right let's get started you
know what a Harlequin is a Harlequin
roll is just surf it's nothing without a
master no one gives two shits who we are
beyond death okay the trailer opens with
1 Harley Quinn and the young Cassandra
Cain with Harley narrating history of
the Harlequin figure now the Harlequin
was originally one of the stock
characters of the Italian slapstick
theatre tradition commedia dell'arte and
those short plays and routines the
Harlequin character was the most well
known the servant character who always
tried to thwart the plans of his boss
similarly this Harley Quinn began in a
sort of servant role and in her
character's history would often subvert
her boss's plans and later would carve
out her own identity now notice the
vibrant colouring of the street purple /
pink lighting on the pavements blue hues
on the steam this reflects the recurring
color palette of this trailer in film
pink and blue matching the dye of
Harley's hair and the dueling roles she
feels torn between as Joker's sidepiece
but really as her own antihero with her
own agency there's a shot of Black
Canary singing in black mask's nightclub
the set design is interesting here a
pair of hands eyes peekaboo in between
the fingers the giant eyes give off to
this kind of big brother Ian voyeuristic
vibe like black mask is always watching
but also the fingers reflect the look of
this black mask who doesn't always
appear in his iconic black skull mask
rather wears black gloves and the face
coverings we do see in this footage have
more of a strap bondage choking texture
a lot like these fingers do did what I
just said makes any sense
depending on your pornhub bookmarks
matey then there's a shot of someone
praying in a chapel with a pipe organ
might be a young Helena Bertinelli
Huntress the comics she was the
surviving daughter of the slain
Bertinelli crime family and as Harley
shares a drink with Black Canary we move
on
the Joker and I broke up I wanted a
fresh start but it turns out I wasn't
the only daemon got them looking for
emancipation okay here the trailers pink
vs. blue color palette extends to the
Warner in DC logos and in the DC one
notice the paint pattern underneath
there's a spatter of pink over an eye
with eyelashes bit of blue and a red
smile smeared over at all the chaotic
rendition of Harley space and throughout
this trailer we hear this awesome song
choice this is Edith Piaf's him that I
love more sorry I don't speak French
this is a song @pf recorded for her
lover and love of her life the French
boxer Marcel Cerdan who tragically died
in a plane crash from Paris to New York
to visit Edith Piaf we look at the
song's lyrics they expressed the mind of
an obsessively devoted lover who offers
to quote dye her hair blonde and to
quote steal fortune dyeing her hair and
theft are absolutely things Harley did
for Joker now in this movie she's
cutting those ties literally chopping
off her blue pigtail marking her
separation from him but at this point
the biggest mystery is what happened to
the Joker now we know birds of prey is
disconnected from the Joaquin Phoenix
earth reflect Joker / Joker was the
Jared Leto Joker from Suicide Squad she
says in Australia that they broke up but
how exactly harley chucks knives into a
drawing of him so did he dump her after
he freed her from prison theatre Suicide
Squad well perhaps the Edith Piaf song
choice might tell us in the PAF biopic
love ian rose with marion cotillard in
the role this song comes up after Piaf
wakes up the morning of Marcel's death
dreaming that he was still alive and he
came home to her but this is before she
was told of the crash and she realized
that he was not there could it be
possible that Harley's former love
suffered a similar fate and his
helicopter crash in Suicide Squad was
actually fatal and that'sa real happy
ending escape from prison
was actually aa love the in Rose PF
style fantasy in our Leigh's room is a
diamond pattern blankets a diamond
pattern is a classic Harlequin design
that shows up in much of Hartley's
clothes and on her arm tattoo and in the
corner there's what looks like a stuffed
panda could be a nod to the Panda man
and Joker's gang from Suicide Squad
Renee Montoya approaches a burning
building all of some thoughts later on
what this crime scene is but then in the
nightclub black Canary's high note
causes this martini glass to tremble
this could be a nod to her
canary cry from the comics a sonic blast
that she can emit we'll see how the
superpower manifests exactly in the film
and then there's a shot every day
walking through a police station bullpen
as other cops applaud without looking at
her this looks as though she might be
getting fired or suspended could be what
leads her to join this rogue gang with
hardly moving on
[Music]
[Applause]
okay here we see Huntress with her
crossbow hard to tell if she's aiming at
Harley chasing her down or if she's
helping Harley by plugging someone who
has cut off Harley in this alley
Harley's pom-pom sleeves here you look
closely include some shredded police
caution tape mixed there's this movies
villain Roman ciona sake a black mask
here he and associate Victor Zsasz have
three captives strung up by their feet
wondering if this could be Cassandra
Cain and her parents we also know that
Ali Wong will be in the cast playing a
police associate of Renee Montoya
maybe Wong is playing Cassandra's mother
and it was her police work that led to
black masks to capture all three of the
family members now again see onus is not
depicted in his iconic black mask though
the trailer that was released in front
of the in chapter 2 film depicted
members of his gang in various colorful
masks suggesting that his false face
society from the comics might come into
play now if you look closely his gloves
have some lettering on them you
definitely make out the letter S in the
middle maybe that's for C onus but to
his left of it there's a B it looks like
maybe that could be for black and then
maybe on the other side there's an M for
mask with s in the middle that could be
black mask Society like they're changing
the name anyway he doesn't school move
to signal the Victor to cut one of their
throats now chris messina plays Victor's
asked villain from the Batman comics
with scars all over his face and neck
for each one of the victims he has
killed you can also see in the close-up
that his knuckles are all bloodied up
maybe from beating the victim on the far
left which could be Cassandra Kane's
father so Harley gets her hyena it's
hard to tell if there's just one there's
another animal movie Medicaid to the
background but I think it's a fox anyway
in Harley's original incarnation from
Batman the Animated Series she had two
hyenas named bud in lieu after the
classic comic duo Abbott and Costello
the idea of them being the pets of the
deranged Joker family Harley placed a
tug of war with a twizzler with her
hyena and nose the hyena wears a pink
bedazzled collar but it's Harley's
collar here that I'm more interested in
she is a dog tag with the name gross
plus another charm which is a fishhook
in the shape of a J maybe for Joker it
could be that these charms might refer
to like X romantic partners and maybe
she wears this badges of honor for just
not just on her belt moving on
[Music]
you need okay hardly Cassandra escaped
these thugs in a warehouse now perhaps
these are Co this is guys later we'll
see you hardly get the jump on these
three and take him down then there's a
shot of Rene looking shocked as she
lowers her gun now perhaps she shot
someone by accident just a bit horrified
by what she's done this could be what
leads to her getting suspended in an
earlier shot hunters confronts a table
of mafia looking dudes in a restaurant
this could be the men connected to the
mob hits on her parents or people she
thinks killed her parents but actually
they lead her to the people who are
really responsible and then see Onis
wearing a shirt with a pattern of his
own face amazing he has some kind of
emotional breakdown and notice how he
stands before this interesting mural or
painting maybe wallpaper of a person's
face covered in a black ribbon a ribbon
that snakes around the neck of another
person choking them again the whole idea
of the black mask is presented in this
bondage aesthetic now at this point the
trailer pf' song is a lyric Gemma foo
right before it gets cut off
mid-sentence by the cloth bag being
taken off Harley space she grins through
her interrogation the nightclub Shifu
means I don't care and we see how hardly
Quinn doesn't care and doesn't let this
interrogation get to her by transporting
herself into this fantasy homage to
Marilyn Monroe singing diamonds are a
girl's best friend in Gentlemen Prefer
Blondes this musical number could be
depicting how Hurley distracts herself
in her own imagination all while
stillness is gay roughs her up it'd be
super dark if that's the case but it's
also exactly the kind of thing Harley
would do notice that all the dancers are
wearing black masks and at one point one
of them fires a machine gun at the
others on to the next section after all
of us
okay harley leads cassandra into this
booby trap funhouse most likely her
Clubhouse perhaps an amusement mile of
gotham we know from the in chapter 2
trailer that a huge fight will go down
in this location all five ladies look
down as if finally defeating a foe they
lower their weapons ray hey as the club
and brass knuckles and this is where
harley rallies the gang looks as though
by rescuing Cassandra Cain a girl all
four queens are interested in protecting
and/or screwing over see onus Cassandra
could be Rene's friend's daughter Black
Canary could be another woman see onus
is forced servitude just what that
happened to someone else
Fiona's could be connected to the hits
on huntresses parents and it looks like
Harley just stumbled onto this conflict
and maybe by taking Cassandra with her
to put a target on all of their backs so
it looks like Victor Zsasz will be one
of the enemies they confront in this
location you'd see that Harley has been
hit with a tranq dart and knocked over
the sofa but later in an overhead shot
it shows as lying dormant on the ground
while the reflection of a gunman gazes
down at them from the skylight and then
a shot of Harley stabbing a body by this
overturned sofa maybe that zazz there
then there's a quick shot with Harley
driving Cassandra and a chase and both
are cuffed to each other maybe they were
both prisoners of black masks
Harley broke the two of them out I also
want to note Harley's top with her name
it looks like the front pocket square is
conveniently censoring a bit of
profanity though this movie is hour
rated won't be surprised if a lot more
words show up on that shirt and a
theatrical cut in this section there are
also some shots of Huntress on her
motorcycle with Harley Quinn and tow on
rollerskates trying to catch up to this
black car which she rides from the
bumper I think this car contains black
mass might now be wearing his mask as he
tries to escape with Cassandra Harley
and Cassandra go on a supermarket
shopping spree filling the cart with
peeps and dog food for the hyena and
Harley jumps on this guy's legs yeah
she's gotta love that reaction for the
table behind her check please
next clip
[Music]
it's hardly pitches order in a pizza
notice the gun case behind her it has
outlines of all of our old automatic
weapons that they're now gone
which is why they now probably have to
use their signature old-school weapons
like the mallet baseball bat crossbow
brass knuckles and another action
sequence hardly appears to be any prison
in disguise shouldn't cop with a beanbag
and hits a fire sprinklers lights a
bunch of dudes John wick style in this
prison perhaps attempting to free
someone then there's a shot of harley
and cassandra taking cover under a table
on explosion tears through the room
based on that wallpaper this is Harley's
apartment and she had the Joker dirt
board in from earlier perhaps hardly
tries to bring Cassandra back to her
flat and it gets targeted forcing them
to move on to a different place we move
on to the next section
who's having a good time more
interesting shots here hardly greets her
hyena more fighting in the prison shots
from nighttime chase but among these is
this one interesting shot of this fancy
parlor and its residents getting shot up
and machine-gun fire Godfather three
style there are also some shots of what
looks like a flashback version of Polina
Bertinelli
marina Tony Soprano style windbreaker
tracksuit on a farm praxis is all
depicting the Mafia assassination of her
parents which happened when she was 19
and on this farm is where she begins her
training with a crossbow to begin her
vengeance path moving on to the last
section I'll accept
ok in this shot list in the cast names
hardly struts away from exploding
building but if you look closely that
building is ace chemicals same chemical
plant and Gotham City where Joker fell
in that open that leached his skin and
as we saw in Suicide Squad the same
place he took Harley back to to
transform her as well but now she
torches the place where she and Joker
became one she steps away from his
possessive control over her and by the
way this looks like the crime scene that
we sell Renee Montoya visiting and that
other shot that we saw and then after
the title card there's this amusing
stinger scene with Harley and Cassandra
where Harley passes her a stick of
dynamite to blow up a pursuer this gag
feels the most like Harley's squad of DC
villainesses Gotham City sirens which
rumors speculate could be the sequel to
this birds of prey film should it be
successful what do you think happen to
Harley's Joker in this birds of prey
movie comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on instagram and
twitter at boss and subscribe to new
rock stars for breakdowns of everything
you love thank you for joining me and if
the only mask that black mask wears and
birds of prey is just like you and
putting his gloved fingers over his eyes
and going woohoo this movie's gonna be
Harley
[Music]